avec ses 8 millions de visiteurs on le
surnomme le plus grand musée du monde à
lui tout seul le louvre pèse près d'un
milliard d'euros
la culture c'est d'abord une affaire
d'état mais aujourd'hui l'argent public
ne suffit plus alors vente de produits
dérivés de cadeaux souvenirs pour le
moins originaux ouverture de commerces
des musées propriétaires de leur propre
parking
tous les moyens sont bons pour faire
entrer de l'argent dans les caisses
comment sont conçus les produits dérivés
à qui profitent les marchands du temple
et à quoi sert cet argent enquête sur
ces musées qui deviennent de véritables
entreprises
c'est un jour comme les autres au louvre
le musée fait le plein sa boutique de
souvenirs aussi
ici les produits dérivés qui rapporte le
plus ce sont les plus petits les moins
chers la reine marie-antoinette est
l'une des stars du magasin et tant pis
si elle a mal fini
on exploite à fond le filon marie
antoinette est un des symboles de la
royauté française et les asiatiques les
américaines en sont folles vous avez le
bol qui a été spécialement développé
pour les
et nationalités asiatiques l'éventail
est le parapluie ici le visiteur dépense
en moyenne 15 euros oui c'est vrai que
c'est un peu cher mais bon je n'ai pas
l'impression de dépenser mon argent
inutile ça paraît peu mais multiplié par
3 millions de clients ça rapporte plus
de 40 millions d'euros par an ce n'est
pas le louvre qui gère cette boutique
mais la rmn la réunion des musées
nationaux
un établissement public dépendant du
ministère de la culture
moyennant un reversement de 15% de son
chiffre d'affaires la rmn peut exploiter
l'ensemble des oeuvres présentes dans le
musée les cartes postales ça rapporte
mais c'est à l'état ce qu'aurélie
commercialise ses plus belles pièces
vous avez le quai louis xiv à 650 euros
la taille de la statue la reproduction
de la manne louis 15 sur sa statue
équestre qui était places anciennement
loin 15 maintenant place de la concorde
celle ci coûte 2500 euros mais la main
de louis 15 ça ne va pas dans tous les
intérieurs
anna et michael ont opté pour un autre
souvenir de leur voyage
ce couple d'australiens est à paris pour
la première fois et ils ont eu le coup
de foudre pour l'une des oeuvres phares
du musée on a visité le louvre
hier tout en haut de l'escalier on l'a
vu hélas on est tombé en extase
on s'est dit waouh c'était la vraie
grandeur nature ils sont prêts à faire
une petite folie pour la victoire de
samothrace mais hésite encore sur la
taille
c'est sûr ils ne la prendront pas de la
taille originale une statue de trois
mètres 28 ça ne rentrerait ni dans leurs
valises
ni dans leur salon je pense que la
prochaine fois que nous reviendrons à
paris on prendra le modèle au dessus et
puis la fois d'après on choisira encore
plus grand mais là on va se contenter de
celle ci pour leur ds en plâtre à nay
michael ont déboursé 220 euros pour
savoir comment sont réalisés ces pièces
nous sommes allés en banlieue parisienne
dans les ateliers de moulage de la rmn
d'habitude les caméras ne rentre pas ici
mais françoise cypher la gardienne des
lieux a fait une exception pour nous là
on est dans la réserve c'est un peu le
saint des saints
la vénus de milo toujours sans ses bras
ou encore le premier code de loi made in
egypte
ce sont tous des moules originaux
uniques certains ont plus de 200 ans
par exemple ce moule du moïse de
michel-ange et dans n'existe quant au
monde qui a été fait sur l'original et
grands pièces en effet que sur comment
vous comprenez bien que on peut pas
habiter c'est un investissement énorme
qu'est ce qu'un moyen pour la classe
pour en mettre un chez soi un colosse
évidemment ça prendre la place compter
en plus 42000 euros pour vous l'offrir
avec plus de 5000 moule la rmn peut
répondre à n'importe quelle demande même
les plus extravagantes et quelqu'un qui
était venu nous demander un vide poche
un peu originale elle a vu la sécu l'a
dit c'est parfait elle a pris pour son
vestibule
pas sûr que ce dieu égyptien aurait
apprécié à l'atelier la star du moment
c'est françois pompon
comme il est mort il ya 70 ans le
sculpteur animalier tombés dans le
domaine public
la rmn n'aura donc plus de droits à
verser aux héritiers 5 à 6 % en moyenne
sur chaque produit vendu
c'est le bon moment pour ressortir les
moules on va refaire un un tirage du
modèle plâtre en fait du taureau de
pompons puisqu'on va laisser une pièce
qu'on va rééditer
la boutique pour septembre du plâtre et
de l'eau pour fabriquer ce taureau vendu
200 euros chez de quatre graals donc
c'était vraiment pas le matériau qui
coûte cher ce qui coûte cher c'est
vraiment c'est le temps c'est le temps
passé et elle travaille de la main de
l'homme c'est ce qui reste plus cher
après vingt minutes de séchage l'objet
peut-être démouler chaque année dix
mille pièces sont produites par
l'atelier mais le numéro 1 incontestable
des ventes du louvre c'est elle ici vous
avez bien sur une île au lagon dole que
joconde avec tous les produits dérivés
joconde l'incontournable mugs nous
savons le parapluie au cube magique
les maniaques font partie des best sur
le frigidaire 97000 magnets vendus
chaque année 178 1000 cartes postales un
euro la joconde c'est la poule aux oeufs
d'or
l'ensemble des musées de france peuvent
lui dire merci c'est en grande partie
grâce à elle qu'ils peuvent enrichir
leurs collections
en fait les bénéfices ont bien sûr
participé à l'acquisition de nouvelles
oeuvres pour les musées mais tout le
monde n'a pas la chance d'avoir une
joconde à exploiter alors comment les
autres musées font-ils pour gagner de
l'argent pour celui du quai branly
célèbre pour son mur végétal et sa
collection d'arts premiers
l'équation est très simple l'état donne
50 millions d'euros chaque année
mais le musée a besoin de 65 millions
pour vivre
karim mouttalib a donc 15 millions
d'euros à trouver pour boucler le budget
il y à bien les entrées payantes mais ça
ne comble même pas la moitié de cette
somme
karim est le numéro deux du musée
sa mission ce n'est pas seulement de
gérer des oeuvres d'un prix inestimable
il est aussi chargé du parking il est
sous le bâtiment il appartient au musée
508 place qui valent de l'or dans le
quartier materis parking fait qu'on fait
on est à 200 mètres de la tour eiffel
donc il ya évidemment le musée qui se
trouve juste au dessus mais la tour
eiffel qui se trouve à 200 m c'est le
seul parking du quartier pour la trouver
c'est une société privée qui exploite le
parking et elle reversera entre 200000
et 800000 euros cette année au musée une
rente à vie
il y en tout trois commerces ici tous
sont gérés par des sociétés privées pour
le restaurant du cinquième étage comme
pour tous les autres c'est le même
système qui a été adopté plutôt que de
faire payer un loyer
le musée est intéressé au chiffre
d'affaires entre 6 et 12%
résultat plus ça marche plus a fait
rentrer de l'argent dans les caisses du
musée
je vois bien on a une présentation
avoisinantes et 90
le chemin à suivre trois aiguilles et de
canards osé et une gambas vous ne le
savez certainement pas mais quand vous
faites une pause déjeuner dans un musée
vont manger presque à tous les coups
chez le numéro trois européen de la
restauration collective et d'autoroutes
depuis quelques années ils investissent
à tout va dans les musées le louvre le
musée d'orsay et le château de
versailles s'est vidé de jean-françois
ici il a dépensé six millions d'euros
pour créer ce restaurant gastronomique
il a le droit de l'exploiter pendant 25
ans et c'est très rentable
on aura un bénéfice positif au goût de
4,5 années de l'équitation
pas avant il faut qu'on importe is les
agissements important quand effet
initialement
c'est un gros business
c'est un bus nous ne soyons pas présents
il peut avoir le sourire le groupe a
fait une très belle opération car il
possède aussi le café brasserie au
rez-de-chaussée c'est de loin le
commerce qui rapporte le plus 500
couverts tous les midis pour 100 places
assises
forcément ça bouchonne il est 2h
d'aujourd'hui se recueillir pour
l'accueil
là vous avez approuvé un recours sont
les gens qui en trois heures de temps
chaque table va servir cinq fois il n'y
a que les fast food pour faire mieux
ces trois commerces rapport près d'un
million et demi d'euros musée au quai
branly
on a décidément la bosse des affaires à
la sortie du coin réservé aux
expositions temporaires
karim a même fait installer une petite
librairie les visiteurs sont obligés de
passer devant le catalogue de
l'exposition vendu à 42 euros part comme
des petits pains et pour le musée là
encore c'est tout bénef en faudra au
minimum dix mille exemplaires parce
qu'on est sur un gros format une très
grosse une très grosse exposition et
notre marge est à peu près de 10 euros
par catalogue et le catalogue rapporte
donc cent mille euros minimum
cet argent sert à acquérir de nouvelles
oeuvres ajoutez à cela les deux millions
et demi d'euros tirés du mécénat ou
encore la location de salles pour des
pinces fesses privé à 25000 euros la
soirée
tmusée qui tendent à devenir de
véritables marques et qui s'exporte même
à l'étranger
le louvre par exemple va ouvrir une
antenne à abou dhabi ça devrait
rapporter 850 millions d'euros musée ils
vont pouvoir en acheter des tableaux
avec tout cet argent